lastly was there anyone from your past a
mentor or someone that you admired you'd
watch from afar maybe that you just
really liked how they handled situations
or you liked how they did things or
their mindset and what was that that's
kind of always stuck with you even if
you didn't really consciously realize it
well I would say I had a personal mentor
Jerry Kass was a playwright from New
York he was a professor that Alex and I
had at Columbia who was a near and dear
friend who unfortunately passed away
some time ago but but he was sort of a
huge influence because when I got to
film school he was one of the first you
know older seasoned writers to come to
you and say I you know I think that you
know what you're doing is really great
work and he was incredibly Curt
encouraging and he we sort of became
family he then you know introduced us to
his wife who's Delia Efron who's one of
the front sisters and she's amazing um
Jerry was my son's Godfather and Delia
was my my son's godmother and so I'm
still very close with Delia but and
she's she's definitely filled some of
that you know space of Jerry's that that
he used to occupy but they've both been
great to us over the years so yes we had
a personal mentor and in terms of of
mentors from afar you know there's
probably a whole bunch I mean I could
say for this project I would say that
there was a we've talked to this before
it's the way that stanley kubrick you
know he started out thinking he was
gonna adapt Red Alert
sort of a furious thriller look at that
nuclear war and then the more he looked
at it the more absurd it was to him and
that ultimately became dr. Strangelove
and I think that you know sometimes
looking at in this case at propaganda at
entertainment as propaganda it's the
more we look the more absurd it became
to us so I think that that least for
this particular project was probably a
bit of an inspiration from the far in
terms of so yet direct meant was I
mentioned Jim Signorelli he was the
director sort of you know kind of
brought me to us and out and you know
was really he'd been around for a long
time he'd been the director that since
1975 and so was just this fascinating
guy that that knew everybody's job on
sets like he could always answer if a
crew member kingdom said we can't do
this he always had an answer for it like
is he he basically been in that
situation before and kind of had a trick
or whatever so I definitely learned a
lot from him but then I was also lucky
that I I kind of grew up with the crew
that I eventually worked with because I
started as a PA at the film unit and
then you know and then was the like you
know became a producer all the
individuals that would eventually sort
of stop you know basically supporting me
once I started directing were all people
that you know when I was you know young
and silly and didn't understand what was
going on with their you know sort of
teaching me and showing what was going
so you know I think them and seeing
their interactions not only with you
know with me obviously but with other
directors I got to do that too you know
like that I would sort of I'd be the one
that come out and we you know we worked
to remember we had Jason Wright and come
in know boom back and then officer Jim
and different people and getting to see
that was who they responded to and the
aspects of you know what they felt like
worked with each person and all that
kind of you know those dynamics I you
know
I don't know that was a really valuable
thing to have that relationship with
those people and sort of see what they
valued in the people that was sort of
you know in charge or you know they were
sort of leaping into battle with and and
so I always you know kind of try to take
two lessons learned from that and and
then you know from afar I think
obviously there are there are influences
and people that I love you know again we
talked on this show you know Brian
DePalma and Roman Polanski you know so
what for me at least you know pretty
important and Jonathan Demi and I mean
full-time Sanderson was kind of without
that humor but he was a sort of watching
Boogie Nights was the first time I feel
like my brain kind of clicked to like
that seeing his direct his hand actually
at work you know I had always loved film
and I grew up you know it's Spielberg
and love those universes but then there
was something in Boogie Nights I just
remember I think maybe I was just at the
right age and so over to that suddenly
it was like no notice if the filmmaking
just became really apparent to me and
what was happening and so yeah there's a
you know there's all moments like that I
think and you know that's what I love
about what doing being able to do this
is that it's a completely fluid industry
and that you you know you never know
everything you you know you continually
get to learn new tricks from people and
learn you know see new things and and
also you know there's constantly new
content coming out that is surprising
you or and teaching you and showing you
different ways of seeing things and yeah
so it's it's you know you get the
opportunities if either you can keep
adapting with it that there's not
there's no rulebook that says well this
is how you do it
it's that's you know that's not that
it's tough at the beginning when you
start the fact there is no rule book is
the most infuriating things you like
what am i doing but once you you know
once you realize that really it is again
it's you get comfortable with your own
sort of understanding of things and and
you know can sort of recognize that it's
it's a wonderful
you